hi there this is steve kaufman uh of
link and the linguist on language blog
today i want to talk about uh
anthony robbins i want to talk about
the kinds of books that people write on
how to motivate people the things that
people say on how to motivate people
and the reason i'm doing this is because
i just finished watching a video that
anthony robbins did
a video that was recommended to me by a
member of link and the video is 38
minutes long i'm going to post a link
here so that you can you can go and
listen to it it's well worth listening
to
and anthony robbins and two other very
successful
internet entrepreneurs all three of whom
have made millions
uh
as entrepreneurs talk about how they
were able to achieve that degree of
success
and uh the thing that strikes me about
the video other than the fact that that
anthony robbins is very motivating full
of energy
and i'm sure people are much more
interested in listening to someone like
him who is young and powerful
than they are in listening to an old
geezer like me
but
the message that he delivers
is actually very much very much the same
as the message that all of these
motivational speakers and writers
deliver
his his message is very similar to that
of uh
covey in his uh seven habits of
successful people uh it's similar to uh
barack obama and i believe it's similar
to mao zedong with his
a single spark can start a prairie fire
uh and so forth and the basic principles
are these and and what struck me about
them is that they very much apply to
language learning in fact they apply
more to language learning than they do
to making money which is what anthony
robbins talks about
and his two friends
and and i think
we can summarize
robin's
message
in the example that he uses of the four
sort of boxes four
uh
steps in a basically a cycle which is
either a vicious cycle or a virtuous
cycle
and he starts with potential and he
claims that we all have this unlimited
potential
and if we recognize this potential then
we will go and take action
and if we take action then we will
achieve results that's the third step
and if we achieve positive results this
will confirm us in our belief that we
can achieve what we want to achieve and
this then increases our potential
and on the other hand if we don't
believe we have potential then we won't
take very successful actions or we won't
persevere in our actions uh the results
will be poor and that will confirm us in
our belief that we can't achieve
anything and this then means that our
potential is decreased or or disappears
so the bottom line is you have to
believe and he he again uses the example
of roger bannister
uh
who he says had to visualize running or
breaking the four minute barrier in the
mile before he could physically run it
so we have to visualize the performance
before we can expect to actually achieve
the performance
and so he his friends talk about how
they visualize owning expensive cars and
and then focusing on making it happen
and then that made it happen
and uh
he also makes the point that people very
often are afraid of failure and
we have to reach the point where we are
more afraid of our existing
unsuccessful situation more afraid of
continuing in that situation than we are
a failure and then we're willing to
take that step and believe and take the
action and then we'll see results and
that'll confirm our belief and then
that'll you know elevate our potential
so uh i think this is so much the case
in in language learning where a majority
of people don't think they can't
visualize themselves as speaking a
foreign language
they don't believe that they have the
potential to do it they therefore don't
have
uh good habits they don't take actions
uh therefore the results are poor and
that it confirms them in the belief that
they can't make a breakthrough in the
language
the good language learners have no doubt
like i never had a doubt i wrote in my
book that
when i was assigned to hong kong to
learn chinese by the canadian government
a friend of mine said well what if you
can't do it and having learned french
through my own efforts largely not
because of how it was taught at school i
had no doubt in my mind that i could do
the same for chinese or any other
language no matter how difficult so i
knew i had the potential it was just a
matter of taking the necessary actions
and that would then enable me to achieve
the results that i wanted that would
confirm me again in my belief that i can
learn any language and so forth and so
on uh in terms of the actions of course
uh you know it's it's also a matter of
these actions being actions that we
undertake ourselves going to a school is
not an action
uh
it's becoming an independent learner
that represents the action and that is
uh the action that's going to deliver
results and if you've taken out taken it
upon yourself to to do this then uh when
you get the results of course it's it's
very satisfying and it confirms
confirms your own beliefs
uh in yourself and in your language
learning potential but it's interesting
that these uh these points that uh
robbins raises
are very similar to covey covey in his
seven habits of successful people talks
about uh you know starting with the end
in mind
and now he has some other
i wouldn't call them homilies but you
know
concepts about uh values in life and
yeah you know respecting your family a
la tiger woods and so on and so on but
but the main concept there is that you
have to
believe that you can achieve it and i i
also bring it back to the the three the
key points that i i once heard this lady
who
who is the head of the san diego
university language department say that
the three basic elements of language
learning are
number one motivation which is that
belief in yourself that confidence
lack of fear
a lot of people have trouble speaking in
other languages because they fear
rejection fear failure they would rather
stay within the comfortable
constraints of mispronouncing the
language
with their own whatever accent they
might have as a native speaker of say
french or japanese on their english say
they would rather stay there than make
that attempt to sound more like a
english speaker or chinese speaker or
whatever so there's that definitely that
that fear angle so that's all part of
the motivation then the second thing
that she said was that you have to spend
the time and that is absolutely true
but time spent sitting in a classroom
uh if there's 20 other learners in there
then the amount of time you are actually
with the language and with the language
as spoken by native speakers is watered
down so that the quality of the time is
also important and i've often hear in
other
videos made the point that nowadays the
new world of the internet and the
ipod makes it possible literally to have
the language with you wherever and
whenever you want
and the third thing that she pointed out
is the importance of being attentive to
the language in other words developing
the habit of noticing what's happening
in the language and this also gets back
to the point that robin's made and that
is you have to take actions but you have
to take meaningful actions and you have
to stay with them
and you don't want to and and i should
perhaps explain that this whole
discussion arousa arose out of the fact
that that link we are now changing the
rules somewhat and we're going to limit
the number of links that is saved words
and phrases that you can keep in a
database as a free member
because we want to force people to
commit and some people are saying well
you should let them use the site for six
months so they get a feel and here again
robbins makes the point you don't need
six months you need a week
you either decide that you're going to
do it or you don't
and so if you are going to decide to do
it make the commitment
now and develop the right habits now we
happen to think that the kind of habits
the kind of functionality
the linking and so forth that's built
into link that these are good habits
do something else it doesn't matter find
some other system it doesn't matter but
decide now that you're going to do it
don't spend six months uh sometimes
doing it sometimes not doing it it's
free anyway i don't feel like doing it
today
i think it's very important that people
are put in a situation where say do i
want to significantly improve or not
and then if the answer is yes then get
going because the sooner you get going
the sooner you will see results the
results will confirm your belief in
yourself which will make you realize
that you have this great potential and
then you will go out and actually
fulfill your potential so have a look at
anthony robbins and i'd be interested in
hearing your comments thank you